this is milford-haven her beauty sport
and conservation area on the tip of west
wales but underneath the sea here lies
all sorts of plastics including
abandoned lobster pots and fishing nets
just goes to show mussels on theirs -
why the boys disappearing the pots are
lost for good and so a group of divers
are trying to remove it in a bid to
clean up our oceans people don't have to
travel halfway around the world to see
something's on their doorstep we've got
grass shame here second largest gannet
colony in the UK birds they were buying
from fishing nets and stuff like that
and ropes that are lost and they're just
hanging themselves on the rock face what
the team here do is undoubtedly a
lengthy and time-consuming process on
the seabed marine life uses the likes of
lobster pots as shelter so they can
often become trapped much like this seal
off the coast of Cornwall that got
tangled up in a fishing net it needed to
be treated before being released back
into the wild
58% of all macro plastics in the ocean
as dose fishing gear so really it's a
huge part of the plastic problem and by
its nature it's designed to caption kill
marine life the top face foundation is
now turning plastics that come from the
sea here in Wales into clothing like
swimming costumes that we can make
people aware of it and that they can
make little changes in their lives
whether it's having a a different cup
for their
or having a you know glass block to law
or not having that not using plastic
bags and things all those little things
that people do can contribute on it on a
much bigger scale loss fishing gear or
so-called ghost gear is among the
biggest killers in our oceans for the
divers here in Wales are trying to
change that Rebecca Williams Sky News